بيروت هل رشحت تفاصيل حول ما حصل
ت ليل الامس قوه تابعه للانفذ وتحديدا
للكتيبه الارلانديه الى اطلاق النار في
منطقه العقبه جنوب لبنان وهي القريبه من
المدينه مدينه صيدا وبالتالي اود ان اذكر
انها ليست المره الاولى التي تتعرض فيها
قوات النيفل لهذه الاعتداءات ولكن ليس
كانت دمويه في بعض التفاصيل بحسب
اندرياتي انت وهو المتحدث الرسمي بس مليون
الف كنت قد تحدثت معه منذ قليل قال لنا ان
هذه الدوريه المؤلفه من مدرعتين كانت
متوجهه منها ان كوره في جنوب لبنان باتجاه
بيروت انحرفت عن مسارها ايه عن
الاوتوستراد الدولي ودخلت الى داخل القريه
حيث حصل اشكال مع اهالي المنطقه واطلق
اهالي او شبان المنطقه النار
باتجاه هذه القوه مع اسفل عن مقتل جندي
ايرلندي واصابه ثلاثه اخرين واحد منهم في
خطر وما زال تحت الخطر حتى هذه الساعه اود
ان اذكر التوفيق انه هناك انقسام في لبنان
حول ما يحصل اليوم منهم من يوجه بالتالي
اصابع الاتهام مباشره الى همم اهالي
المنطقه وهم التابعين لحزب الله حيث
القاعده الشعبيه اللي الثنائيه الشيعيه هي
في الجنوب اللبناني واللي ما يحصل لقيته
هم مسؤوليليا عن هذه الاعتداءات في حين
انه من الجهه الاخرى طلبوا همم او طلبت
الجهات التابعه للثنائي الشيعي بضروره
الوصول الى تحقيقات مناسبه
شكرا لك جويل مارون من بيروت